oh there it is
see aliens confirm here what is that
like some sort of
yeah it looks like a flying saucer what
does that mean is that music in the
background what is that
I could do without the trumpet in the
background what kind of music is that
they put with that
[Music]
you don't need to put music if you see a
UFO you don't need to put dramatic music
with it's already pretty dramatic at
least at least to me that one okay you
see that video and you think well that
could be anything you know who knows
what that is and true I mean that could
be anything but it's the again you look
at the totality of the evidence there's
so many videos just like that